Shania Twain is looking back on her
memorable dinner day with Oprah Winfrey
revealing where it all went wrong all
right first of all Shania and Oprah at
the same dinner table where was our
invite because it's not in the mail all
right during a recent appearance on the
table manners podcast Shania learned a
few table manners herself while we're
calling the one thing she regretted
discussing with Oprah at the dinner
table
I think one of my most memorable dinners
was
um yeah with Oprah Winfrey oh yeah who
cooked or did you eat out we ate out she
just as wonderful as we all think she is
oh she is I mean she's such a smart lady
and you know we just it was just great
to just sit and have real talks you know
and
but as soon as we started talking about
religion it all went sour why so oh
let's stop talking about religion is she
religious
she is quite religious yeah okay you
um not religious
in the sense that I'm dedicated to a
religion you know I'm I'm very I'm much
more of a spiritual person I'm much more
of an inner
I'm a Seeker I'm with them a Seeker but
at least you knew to just stop it right
there right so that was like okay yes
I've entered into
you know however everyone always says
never talk about that politics yeah
absolutely mum loves to talk about both
don't you Mum yeah and that was what it
just wasn't debatable there was no room
for debate and I like to debate
Canadians like to debate about it you
know debate everything
so I'm like oh okay it's time to change
subject
first of all she eating the entire time
I've never heard this podcast before but
it's fascinating I love that and can we
get on this show because we would like
to eat something no um yeah that's it
you don't talk about religion you don't
talk about politics you don't bring up
those really intense conversations at
the dinner table it's never gonna go
right because I think everyone's
interpretation of religion and
spirituality and all of those things are
very personal to the person and it's
hard you don't want to ever project your
own beliefs necessarily on other people
and so yeah I think that was really
smart if if you're just
potentially not on the same page like
just take a right turn or just listen
and and hear what they have to say it's
also a good opportunity to learn yes oh
my really
it's always I think it's always
interesting to hear different people's
abuse and beliefs and all of those
things but
um I can see how it can get tricky yeah
because I was at having dinner with a
family member and they're supporters of
trump and it just went like there's one
thing I know it but it was but religion
did come up actually
um and it was the whole Roe v Wade
situation and we had this discussion and
the perspectives were so interesting and
I just thought they were completely
wrong but when you look at their point
of view of how they see things I think
it's still completely wrong but it's
interesting the way they think about
things and twist it so it's you know but
it's again it shouldn't have been at the
dinner table it went on and the food got
cold but if you were to able to sit down
with somebody and have a discussion
celebrity who would you invite Ryan
Reynolds and Hugh Jacks that would be so
much fun given the fact that they just
released those teasers yeah or you know
Deadpool and everything but so that
would be mine what about you I'm gonna
go with The Rock
and what would that discussion be about
Fitness The Rock uh yeah the rock yeah
like I I think anybody fun anyone that
could just have a good conversation with
would be great even Jennifer Lawrence
that would be so amazing to sit down
chat with her but yeah I think any
celebrity who's willing to eat and have
a good time is welcome at my table
[Music]